I want you to murder your family in your
pool I want to bathe in the blood of
your children
I would totally suck your dick if you at
home and fist-fought your mom whitey
Ford himself from the House of Pain
Everlast is coming into studio with us
which is very very exciting didn't feel
a pop in the room I said it but all
right every would you want us all to
each other talking about it for hours on
the camera people didn't do anything
white Lou who I know is exploding with
excitement for this did he want to jump
around
ever lasted this freestyle on a on an
IceCube compilation album in the 80s
that I'm dying to ask him about yes
syndicate when he was part of syndicate
oh my god I'm so sorry that's exactly
what I've been looking for my
entire life
yeah the syndicate Jays deep knowledge
of Everlast ice-t background too
but that what what is that song remember
I know
Everlast his rhyme on that was the my
favorite
he's towards the end yep Everlast had a
like a long ponytail no I thought you
said hair it's just that here it's just
just hair bro oh there it is - I
remember listening this in the back of a
jeep in Clearwater Florida
last part
Gobbo we're bobcats dad - you are blue
here we go that's three burials up here
we go I'm curious he recently little bit
younger - pretty cool still we've got
like 10 minutes so we got to put this
together put together I just thought
it'd be funny if give him a break his
aide said he's been going around playing
music on all these shows he's having a
sing songs and we have an acoustic
guitar here well yeah well I'll just be
playing it on accident and then be like
oh I didn't know you were gonna be here
oh maybe you can play we don't a hammer
it with him or Susie walks in yeah yeah
but maybe just have you could be holding
the whole time and go - oh my guitar
view yeah do you want take your shirt
off already a so you have your shirt off
of the guitar answer it's like you've
just been Weiland yeah his bird
he's been hitting some some tasty liquor
I just been shredded shredded in the
corner of the studio
yeah yeah I'm into that whatever you
need to talk to him for a while and
having a nice conversation everyone be
you have to have questions forever last
okay way you know yeah what was it like
scoring judgment night remember you got
judgment night you want to tell me what
it's like was he I think it was in
judgment I think yes Gary
living off a building he's one of the
guys did you have an ask who he was in
judgment night bo can I tell you who's
one of denis leary's crew you're denis
leary's crew don't ever come back
this best song house of pain and
helmets the best song on the soundtrack
I'm sorry I love that song oh my god I
am the biggest ever let's fan the world
just a victim code it's the best dude I
his all like well playing when we come
back from break action let's play we go
back to break oh is this it
yeah that's helmet house pain oh
here is right here just kidding guys
dude by the way Jake Jacobson I walk in
assholes ever long the entire time dude
he's reached play Everclear every time
we come back we get to the thing before
we have to go to break yeah just say
what I think it'd be funny to do if we
can get him if we can get him to do it
if he will agree to play the song what
it's like you know he's so funny if we
all take turns try to keep a straight
face and singing a verse of it but like
singing about whatever I still want to
do the thing we were doing when Bert
first came in if we always take turns
going but we were at this verse where he
goes what is it summing up what's her
name
we kept doing Jake something got from a
kid named Thompson uses up said the
whooping thing jig gonna be the man I've
been thinking of Mike can you hand Bert
the guitar so we can do what we were
doing when Bert first came in yeah Jacob
got a producing job said Hughes and uh
you see the word about that shock to
some amazing dreamin uh why do you jump
don't bubble the man himself girl didn't
know she was a hole but wait I could
watch that $60 go out the door
we might be borderlining like if
someone's like hey doing impression of
bird look I'm a drunk idiot I dig my
shirt off it's like a shitty Tom Waits
yo you want to hear my Dan Soder hey let
me show me in my present to you
are you guessing I don't sell that is a
great idea four hours well then will you
also get other chefs in the kitchen
realized maybe not the best idea to
pressure to someone's face maybe birth
believe you I think that's what a black
face the problem of a black face this is
what we think you look like so don't
soft you either it sounds like we're
just doing you alright worry brother
thanks brother all right
brother brother I'll break anything
except bread with the Jew
I bet you turn on that let's do it I
gave you every opportunity sometimes we
think we're gonna take a break and then
we find that our guest only has a very
very limited time yeah so yeah he's here
we actually just played that song for
him where he's in the hallway yeah joins
us on the bonfire yeah this is great
they never give us cool guests this this
is the best oh yeah
Tony I got to pop in I was like I'm
literally on my way to the airport but I
was like I'm not just gonna like flake
let's go yeah
oh then we would have bet Jay would have
been just we're goin y'all yeah this is
exciting for me also because what less
than a year ago at a deli by my house a
month after I saw you perform with House
of Pain at Irving Plaza
I bumped in you at a deli and told you
that my radio I said on my radio show we
made we voted you the coolest white boy
white boy um yeah we shook hands I was
certain after you left as I said to my
girlfriend was with me at the time to
Christine over there I did say I go I
was just any one of those guys now who
just did that thing hey once you tell me
you were related in some way you also
did it like a kind of a weird fringe
thing where you go I got radio show and
you're like I'm gonna die and then I
think I listed some of my TV's credits
it was not a good I was on Comedy
Central I was on IFC I was in flip-flops
and socks made it know how to react I
didn't know was gonna bomb never left
does that happen when you're out getting
food just people just like look at you
like oh hey if I got my you
face on or not yeah Helen you try to
keep it awesome to Allah Ya Allah what's
the thing that people can say to you
that hits you where you go oh you're
legit fam
like where you go like by some guy just
mention my new special what if I say
that then I who at least whoever's
listening
I use it every time they see me here's
how these are good people if I approach
the airport Argo judgement night changed
my life yeah here we go mine is mine
I'd say the movie or the soundtrack
would let me know you've been rocking
for a while for sure you stole that from
me
acoustic when you did that that's a yes
yes I was the first one into any music
on I don't know if a lot of people still
do I know one or two other bands and on
shows I'm about to go here just show
some were you guys at the Irving Plaza
show where I was singing every word up
in the balcony
oh you guys are probably too busy eating
cereal and playing video games or
something oh well you guys are probably
tough mudder training or something so I
was over there white boy
wrapping it up in the balcony do you
realize you're giving in more to the
myth that you're the psycho fan that's
like I voted you the best person I was
on at the top of the theater for three
hours you never came out I had a
Father's Day card for you like your
faith I don't remember any of the notes
but it was only in New York nice target
ham sandwich date I'm not
walking into a shitty deli in Paris and
ordering like snot morning here oh I'm
just not trusting yeah the Boar's Head
is what sells me you were getting a
sandwich that's how I had you hostage
you were probably high and you probably
were wait you were weighing in a dress
that's not this fat annoying idiot who's
wearing a tank top comfortably the
biggest psycho move would have been if
you finished the sandwich order for him
and you go he also likes regular mustard
I need it back there's no salt your
blood pressure at the doctor's office I
tried to talk to you then - where did
the name Everlast come from as a fan
since I've been a kid I used to be my
had a really when I was first started
rapping Mike McCaul myself a rocky which
was Eric rocks everlasting I just
chopped that right to hell last
ever last I'm such a huge fan for such a
long time such a long time since
I was 8 17 years old how do you
seventeen is it I know you know jump
around probably to some degree the bane
of your existence in many ways but I
mean it's well I've heard it go
different ways John popper told me from
Blues Traveler that he'll play the
what's the runaround song whenever and
he won't even ask me to play it on the
street because he's like that bought me
everything I've ever had I guess so some
people don't run from it at all but I
mean like the only time jump around was
a problem to me is when I first released
whitey Ford sings the blues I'd put it
away and write you know and I wouldn't
do it for probably about 2 or 3 years
and you do acoustic versions of it which
is awesome - yeah that was looking like
a few years back I did an acoustic album
yeah just was like it I'll do it
before some hipster does remember the
idea I told you about where I was gonna
do jump around acoustic well yeah I
ruined that for him you don't have to
answer this just but like there are some
lines you leave out when you did the
accursed acoustic version I own the
album and why did you come out yeah yeah
I'm old and I forgot this is how we
approached you about having CTE I loved
I bought the album I loved it I loved I
watch you live are you gonna make me
listen to it
right there if you could play it I swear
to god I'll get totally naked are you
want whatever you want I'll do I'll get
naked
I'll give you my entire going up here's
everything I did he was like I don't
think it's any of those things gluten
free coconut ball what the new album
why do you force house of pain is all
new music yeah
that's my first studio album in about
eight years is it more is it more
singer-songwriter this one or no it's
kind of like everything in the toolbox I
brought back a some more hip hop ins and
a couple hip hop producers friends of
mine got like a little black singing on
and I got my guys slug from atmosphere
doing it he's a great guy that's
awesome is it is it is it to the point
now where you're having just like fun
making the music I've always have fun
writing jump around
and and what it's like and then puts
your lights on I can do whatever the
I want
yeah I know I don't have to I can make
what I want to make doesn't matter if it
wins or loses that's great you know
luckily I never lose to tough and I win
pretty decent yeah I own my own masters
I don't my own label I know I do alright
so I'm I'm I'm I look at cats that are
way bigger and richer than me and I and
I know they're slaves to the game yeah
and I don't envy them in a lot of ways I
inverted the bank account no I'd love to
have the bank account don't get me wrong
but not if it comes with like I one of
the first times I was ever on Rogaine I
said something like I like going to
Ralph's and sanding at the Olive bar and
getting my own are lips like jump around
plan and nobody knows I'm there
dude I love that but like I heard
Dan Kastner Ella from The Simpsons say
that about doing Homer he's like he's
like I have a life I can just go have a
life and and and I'm like one of the
most iconic he's super rich
master stuff and I just know I'm dumb
that even if I got success there would
be a thing where they're like no you
sign that away early on Reba that's the
money right there is I don't want to
jump around master okay okay I own all
the Masters of since I left the major
label album jet pack at home you get it
back at some point no but I mean I own
the public I stole all my publishing um
it's it's just when you did record deals
they own the Masters that's the way it
was back then you know yeah it's not a
horrible thing I still get paid do you
get excited if you when you're in a bun
yo the Masters you get all nice when
you're in a bar on st. Paddy's Day and
they play jump around okay so we're
talking what ninety four last time that
happened okay no actually that's not
true st. Patty's is a big payday for me
I forget
that's what this huh if any of us
here jump around we lose our it's
inevitable that all of us starts just
bopping like oh yes there's a funny
thing usually around December I start
getting competing on who wants me on
actually saying how I usually do like
for things like around that weekend or
whenever st. Patty's Day when it falls
and but there's always a nice little
like fight between who gets him one st.
Patty's Day you also you also wrote the
anthem for the NBA's first second of the
game every I haven't been with Stadium
it doesn't start playing jumping before
the jumps I think it's most sporting
events honestly I don't think there's
any sporting event I've never heard it I
haven't heard of that oh yeah I was I
went to the World Cup of cricket and
really yeah yeah that's so it was a
while ago but it was Pakistan vs.
Australia so I don't know your phone
that might be everyone my brother plays
cricket would you like to come tickets
to the World Cup of cricket I was like
yeah dude it's funny though cuz you
think you know in baseball and MLB they
come up to songs and a cricket they do
they're like now bunting for Pakistan
yeah I would make another cricket
reference but I know nothing whatever
they're weird point-scoring
thing is is that weed or do you try this
one I kind of dispensable what I won't
touch it if you're cool but when reasons
I say like I'm a germophobe because
my oldest daughter was born with cystic
fibrosis God and real so it's I don't
know I only bring it up because we like
to raise awareness yeah so look it up
I'm a big ghoul so when you say that I'm
like Bill right yeah I get it I just
want like it's one of the things like
when people like walking over me and
likes just sticking your hand out is
gonna get your feelings hurt yeah
most times yeah yeah a pound huh you do
a knuckle pound yeah yeah I'll be like
that's the thing I'll do I'll give you
one of these and people get that look
sometimes like alright
is it because you don't want to bring
germs into your house I don't want to
touch you but I don't want to I don't
want my your anything like this is wet
this is dry most people wouldn't be wet
mine is when most people shouldn't be
but sometimes yeah I just can't do that
I'm gonna I'm gonna use an entire
pint of sanitizer after
do you always have it on you you always
got the hand sanitizer I just ran out
today but yes do you think I get some
more before I get to the point how are
you with like doorknobs and stuff like
that I have alcohol wipes she just
constantly all day yes I just watched a
couple get on the subway my way up here
and they're like wiping down the bar no
sitting across and I was kind of like
what licking I don't give a Jacobs
giving me the word that you got to go
you got to catch a flight to man no I'm
gonna come back though for real are you
gonna tour on the album yeah I'm in
Europe I'd leave today I go home for two
days with my kids and I'm Russia and
Europe all September are you doing
coming back I got a we're doing a UFC
pre-party thing you want to show at the
Brooklyn Bowl in Vegas tonight before I
McGregor
could be posted oh I will album whitey
Ford's House of Pain hopefully we'll see
when you come perform in New York
minutes turn off your GPS I'll be on the
top row singing every song is the
bonfire
any more ice - got you got hammered with
Everlast can you I try to get high with
him he shot that down my regret was
basically me asking ever less if you
wanted to have a catch no you guys made
my Delhi interactions seem downright
awesome sing a song I'll get butt
naked right now
great dance licking things in off room
to another school bombard it up
instead of leave right away
heaven knows breathing stairs take me
bare crawling around a room
of stories but my core strength is you
get me a small two-bedroom I
will like you well Jay is just
going hey hey and then it goes like this
just to show you want some this is pizza
you